foreign
hi everyone welcome to next 22.
I'm Vidya shanmugam product manager for
bigquery in this session we're going to
talk about how you can manage your data
silos and simplify your data analytics
across multiple clouds
I have with me to offer valued customer
speakers and one Cast X from L'Oreal and
Luis Polanco from Accenture
let's talk data
over the last decade we've seen a
massive explosion in data both in data
types and volume
data is also increasingly split across
multiple storage systems data warehouses
relational databases object stores Etc
with the proliferation of new
application data is serving many new use
cases data Sciences bi analytics
streaming and the list goes on
data is also increasingly spread across
multiple clouds in fact majority of the
Enterprises globally have data sitting
in a mix of cloud platforms
with these emerging data Trends more and
more customers are gravitating towards
multi-cloud data leaks this also
presence our customers with several
challenges such as data silos data
duplication fragmented governance
complexity of tools increase cost and so
on here is where big league and Omni
come in to help build and manage your
data leaks across clouds at scale we
launched Big League General availability
earlier this year Big Lake provides a
standardized survey across different
storage formats including bigquery
managed tables blob stores open file
formats Omni provides the compute Engine
with which you're able to access and
query data in your AWS or Azure
environments seamlessly using bigquery
UI Omni and Big Lake together provide
several key benefits first a single pane
of glass to query your multi-cloud data
leaks second cross Cloud analytics by
combining data across platforms third
unified governance and secure management
of your data wherever it may be let's
dig deeper into these benefits
bigquery Omni provides a single unified
view for your data across all of these
clouds it is serverless we manage all of
your infrastructure and Hardware needs
we provide secure management of your
data across AWS Azure and gcp
let's see this with an example let's
take a gaming company that has different
titles and player data spread across S3
Azure data leak bigquery managed storage
and Google storage
these are all separate data sources that
are residing in different clouds as you
can see all of these data sources are
available to an analyst or data
scientist in a single unified view you
can query any of this using bigquery UI
and familiar SQL language you can also
set access policies and tags and have
consistent fine green governance across
all of this data
it's great to access and query
multi-cloud data through a single view
but we also know that you want to
combine and integrate these data sets we
recently launched a capability called
cross-cloud transfer in preview with
which you can first query the data that
you want to join in AWS or Azure using
Omni this Hub filter just relevant data
sets with the SQL load statement then
you can bring subset of that data into
gcp as a managed table you are now able
to combine data across clouds with
little egress costs what more this also
dramatically reduces the time to insight
as no wholesale migration of data is
actually needed with the cross cloud
data now being available in bigquery you
can access it through local data Studio
other bi tools for all your Advanced
analytics needs
we're also building features for
cross-cloud Transformations you can run
an ad hoc query in AWS S3 perform local
Transformations and create a table
directly in a bigquery region all using
SQL with your data now available in
bigquery you can join it with any other
gcp data we are continuing to invest
heavily in the space including
capabilities such as cross-cloud
materialized views we know that seamless
way to do cross-cloud analytics is very
important to you
lastly I'm excited to share some
features that provide unified and
consistent governance of your data
across class
throw on these integration with data
catalog you can discover search your
tables across clouds add relevant
business contacts with business glossary
and Rich text that's now available you
can also centrally manage access
controls and policies at row and column
level via big league tables irrespective
of where your data is with future
dataplex integration you will have the
ability to manage these access policies
at skip
coming soon as also data lineage support
with dataplex integration with this you
can track your data flow and
dependencies of your data creation and
Transformations for Big Lake tables
now that you've heard about some of the
key benefits of omni let's talk about
how you can get started
we have launched a new trial offer for
Army with this you can query your data
in Omni regions using on demand at no
charge there is no need to provision or
purchase slots to run your omnicrays
this is a limited time offer until March
2023. we also now have Google self-based
labs to set up on me so don't wait to
get started with that let's transition
to Antoine to hear about how Omni has
helping L'Oreal in their data challenges
thank you Vidya and thank you for the
invitation for having me and Laura
behind me the number one Cosmetic
Company in the world so before telling
you why we are using Omni let me tell
you why bigquery and it is for one very
simple reason as you can see on my slide
we don't want to manage the
infrastructure not at all why because we
are not an I.T company
what do we prefer to do instead of of
that is focusing on the data that we put
on bigquery the added value provided by
this data is clearly more important for
the Royal people
let me tell you the challenge that we
have at lawyer which is the biggest one
the acquisition of the different Gwen
and it happened trust me many many times
and it will continue to happen in the
future so challenges here how is it a
challenge and how we can do that before
having Harmony in the pocket so before
Omni we were having almost three main
challenges one was the time to Market
delivery it was very very long and it
was a big difficulty the second was the
diverse ecosystem we have to manage
because of Duty of different technology
coming from different companies and at
the end the complexity of the governancy
in terms of multiple technology multiple
languages and securization of everything
in one place
so the benefit of omni in that story
they are very very very clear the data
can be hosted from all over the world
the place you want the data can be
queried very very easily in one central
place and that prevents any
duplication or moving the data so it is
better in terms of cost optimization but
also in terms of sustainability which is
very very important for Loreal so at the
end and probably the most important one
we keep a one and one only ways of
working across all the developer that we
have over the world they use only one
languages which is the SQL
so as a result of this deployment what
can we say we can say that the result of
that this diploma we made a benchmark to
compare Omni versus the competitor of
the market and you can see on that slide
that the performance are clearly better
again as I said before having one way of
working using SQL standard is again I
want to tell you again that it is very
very important for lawyer the governance
we can adopt because now everything is
centralizing one place is also very
important for us and at the end having
an overview of everything in one single
pane of glass was also a very very big
benefit of that
so to finish I have a very quick example
of the usage of Bitcoin the cross Cloud
analysis imagine Loreal wants to launch
a new product they want to compare data
coming from of course the Google
analytics telling me the sales the
audience my customer everything I need
to know and data coming from other
companies so now with Omni I can
aggregate this data in just one central
place to have a very very quick answer
so thank you Vijaya for the invitation
back to you
thank you so much Antoine for talking to
us about L'Oreal's acquisition
challenges and how cross-card analytics
is helpful for you now we'll hear from
Louise about how Omni big lake and
dataplex are a key part of accenture's
data platform strategy thank you Vidya
and thanks for having me here today to
get us started let's take a look at our
Center as a company so we can understand
our data complexity when we're running
our businesses Accenture is a global
Professional Services that today has
more than 700 000 people working all
around the world all these employees
Genesis data and consumes data while
they are doing their work
as a global company our technology
direction is funded on a multi-cloud
strategy cloud is automatically setting
us up to take advantage of any data
capability that core class providers are
offering our employees generated an
amazing amount of data that it is
distributed in a multi-cloud environment
and we use that data to empower our
teams and leaders to make data targeted
issues in My overall Accenture I am part
of the team responsible for empowering
the people with the buy data and with
the right tools the team is managing our
Global I.T data platform that it is
really unlocking the value of data
innovation in the cloud
to deliver value with all this data at
the scale we adopted Google Cloud
platform as a service as the platform to
host the business data that we have
partly with Google we decided a data
platform on gcp that can handle all the
data requirements that we have in our
globality organization
following the customer's your principle
we've been adapting and adopting new
technologies ensuring we will meet in
our business security and Technical
requirements and that is important for
Accenture because we use ourselves later
as a living example when we're helping
our clients to do the same with these
Technologies
the platform provides ingestion
processing storage and security service
and contains today more than 600
terabytes of business data our users are
running more than 390 these applications
using services like composer data block
data flows or vertex AI
but as a multi-cloud company we know
every cloud and every technology has its
benefits when processing data and we're
going to ensure all these benefits are
available to our end users when they are
generating value to the business
when you're offering your business in a
multi-cloud environment data is
distributed across clouds and that
complicates the data management
distributed management is one of the
most common problems we see in our
customers when they have data on
multiple clouds in this scenario the
number of data producers and consumers
proliferate and the domain complexity
increases because data is now required
in multiple places and for different
purposes and all of that makes sense the
problem is that has directed impact on
your platform at the scale if you're
increasing your data footprint because
you are copying data multiple times
across different clouds you are probably
your data Ingress processing or egress
multiple times with different pricing
models your data consolidation is now
time and cost intensive and the security
model gets decentralized you need
multiple tools to manage it and what it
is even more important now your people
require multi-cloud skills data
scientists power uses and data consumers
in general have now to deal with
different Technologies to produce
insights making the job more complicated
and probably less efficient
the focus is the data and how you can
use that data for generating business
benefits and it is not the technology
but let me give you an example in our
Global I.T we're running multiple
research use cases where we want to
simplify how we're connecting the data
our data scientists are exploring data
that it is distributed in different
places across the cloud they need
agility when they are accessing the data
and the ability to join this information
across clouds they need to understand
how much value they can generate in the
business even before we're moving the
solution into production
but because data spread in multiple
places I want to assign this past week
for having this data valuable in the
platform in the meantime we have our
data Architects that are literally
stressed preparing and moving this data
and the business perceives that data
prices are less low and probably they
cannot resolve the problem sometime
the key question is how can you simplify
the data so the usage experience is
better than a multi-cloud scenario
we're looking for some kind of data
virtualization that allows our data
scientists to get into the data speed
with the ability to connect this
information during earlier stages of the
project but without having to wait
but without having to wait for all the
data available in the platform
but these cases bigquery only seems a
good match Google and Accenture having
collaborating together for the last 12
months on bigquery only using Accenture
as customer zero together with we'll all
need to support our Enterprise needs
following with example data scientists
are using dashboard and application for
the exploration and they need typically
to consume from many different data
sources we want to speed up their data
exploration use cases so the research
can be executed early in time but
without moving the data today we're
moving all these data requiring one book
exporting to the platform instead of
having this big bound One-Shot approach
we're exploring bigquery only as the
tool to identify the right data sources
bring in the necessary data for analysis
to do this incrementally this helps
deliver value immediately along with the
data management costs overall
we have seen a lot of power when
combining Accenture industry expertise
with Google Innovative Technologies I
think it's a win-win relationship that
facilitates adapting these Technologies
to the Enterprise using Accenture as
customer zero as we go deep in this View
and collaboration there are many new
cases that icing Beyond only we are
working towards a better management
model of data hosted in gcp using
dataplex we're exploring how we can
simplify the access and security of data
store on files using big lake and we
perceive there is a lot of power when
mixing bigquery Omni dataplex and big
like Twitter
so that's probably a brief summary of
what we're doing with Google and
Accenture to get in the data space and
as you can see there is greatness when
we're mixed like sensory Innovative
thinking with Google Cloud net products
that is a great energy collaboration
that it's reverting directly into our
customers in the digit of your video
back to you
thank you so much Louise and Antoine for
sharing with us how bigquery Omni is a
key part of your data strategy
you saw a Omni building together with
big lake and dataplex can help manage
your multi-cloud data performance here
it provides several benefits including a
single pane of glass cross-cloud
analytics and unified governance get
started with your Omni on demand trial
now thank you everyone for tuning in to
next 22. enjoy the show
[Music]